لقد حافظت على نسبة الثواني للمديرين التنفيذيين المسؤولين عن التمثيل
وهو رئيس الشركة "ب" لحزب العمال المؤسس ، ورئيس مجلس الدولة لجمهورية كوريا الشعبية الديمقراطية.
الرفيق كيم سونغ إيون ، الذي يعرّفها ، ليلاً في مبنى بولب بعد العام المركزي لنظام حزيران (يونيو).
وقد عقد جلستين بين اللجنة المركزية ومسئولي الوضوح والمسؤولية بالحزب الإقليمي
جو يونغ وون دونغ ، عضو اللجنة الدائمة للمكتب التقدمي الأوسط للجنة المركزية لحزب العمال الكوري.
الرفاق وسكرتير الحزب ، الذي سيصبح رئيس الأركان العام المقبل
شارك في الاجتماع
هناك ، قبل الاجتماع الكامل للجنة المركزية للحزب ، وتنفيذ السياسة الرئيسية في النصف الثاني من هذا العام
إذا نظرت إلى الحالة المحددة التي أثيرت في
ناقشنا القضايا العملية ، إلخ.
التفاوض على العيش مع 4 بنادق غير محددة
القضايا المثارة كأمر مسلم به فيما يتعلق بالمشاريع الاقتصادية الوطنية وأمن سبل العيش
مراجعة الطب الخاص بك
لم ير عازف البيانو مهمة مهمة لساحة الإعدام
الرفيق أرسنال ، وليس جون ، كان كل سكرتير للجنة المركزية للحزب الذي تعامل مع الوضع الحالي.
مقترحات لتوجهات الأعمال والبحوث للمحافظات والجهات الحكومية
أثناء كونك ابن أخ ، اغتنم تناوب الغرفة في المدرسة الإعدادية فرصة الاجتماع وأعمال الاقتصاد الوطني وحياة الناس
لقد سعيت وراء فكرة إحداث ضائقة حقيقية من خلال كونك مستقرًا.
الأسلحة النارية التي ليست ورقة غنائية
اللجنة المركزية للحزب الكلب الغذاء الحكومة المسؤولين التنفيذيين لكل لجنة حزب المقاطعة
كن على علم بمهمة المرء والنار
عندما نسعى جاهدين لنبذل قصارى جهدنا مع الاضطلاع بمسؤوليتنا المشرفة عن مصير وطننا وشعبنا.
النظر في التحقير
تنمية اقتصاد الدولة ورفع المستوى المعيشي المادي والثقافي للشعب
فيما يتعلق بمسألة التسعير الكبير في عام أثيرت من قبل
أخذت استراحة من Karl 7 sim الأكثر إشراقًا.